c'est désormais une tradition chaque été
la ferme de quelle île vous propose de
venir participer à un barbecue champêtre
un moment familial amusant et dépaysant
le principe est assez simple les gens
viennent dans les labyrinthes qui se
trouve derrière moi ils viennent avec
leurs repas leurs l'avion qui veulent
faire cuire les légumes
nous on
m'allumer barbecue et on leur met à
disposition deux sites
si les 10 mai au barbecue est la
principale attraction la ferme de gagnet
a prévu plein d'autres activités au
programme visite des labyrinthes jeux de
bois ou encore danse sur des musiques
traditionnelles où on a un groupe de
musique folklorique qui vient animer ses
soirées et donc qui est très
participatif qui fait toujours un petit
peu des familles des groupes d'amis en
demandant un truc est de 15 régions ils
sont et puis y joue des musiques
traditionnelles de ces régions il invite
les invite les gens à venir danser s'ils
le souhaitent
aulas est très bon enfant la soirée
prend place sur quatre hectares une
surface qui permet facilement de
respecter les règles sanitaires
la spar et s'étend de 19h à 22h30 les
prochaines soirées se dérouleront les 5
12 et 19 septembre